all right Shea is with us in Arizona hi
show welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave how are you better than I deserve
what's up how can John and I help you my
boyfriend and I succeeding we're going
to talk about getting married and I feel
a little guilty
your phone is going weird kiddo can you
speak directly into it yes that's a
little better yeah all right my
boyfriend and I about a year and they're
starting to talk about getting married
and I feel kind of guilty knowing he's
gonna shoot up and find and take a train
when he saws a lot of day my thinking no
way you're feeling guilty that he's
saving up to buy an engagement ring well
he has a lot of debt oh yeah
what does he make 44 and how much debt
does he have he has about 79 cars and
what came to him 17 on a car and what 20
to 22 on student loans and have you guys
discussed this ring thing enough that
you might have an idea what his budget
is no okay well if he were healthy
financially he's not I would tell him as
an old man to a younger man don't spend
more than one month's take-home pay on
the ring that's enough
there is no statistical correlation
between the size of the diamond and the
marriage lasting as a matter of fact
when the diamond gets to a certain size
there's an inverse correlation so
meaning that if she needs a rock that
big she probably ain't yours and so it
doesn't work but anyway so so a good
woman like you that asks a question like
you're asking is very mature and very
kind in spite of the fact that you're
scared I'm going to say don't buy a ring
because you really do want one unless
you're just unless you're just weird and
I don't think you're weird so I think
you need to get a ring so let's get a
ring that
has a reasonable budget the guy has a
car he can't afford he probably needs to
sell that anyway and let's let's talk
about you know is a forty four thousand
so his take-home pay is probably three
grand a month if so if three grand was a
normal max you know because he's got a
lot of debt let's cut it in half and
let's get started with a starter ring
right a fifteen hundred dollar ring by
the way my wife Sharon got married to me
with a the engagement ring was point two
three carats
it wasn't even 1/4 of a carat and that
sweet precious romantic little ring is
in the safe and she wears a headlight
now on her hand so it's it's a starter
ring it doesn't you're not stuck with it
it's not you know b85 wearing it
probably if you guys go and win but I
don't think you need to feel guilty if
he spends $1,500 or less in cash
honoring especially if he's making other
moves John what do you think Shea how
big of a ring do you want I mean
obviously I want something for you to
wear the rest of my life but I mean
that's not worth ruining our financial
future that's that's that's the question
I wanted to hear your answer to so good
for you and so I think I love what Dave
said I think it's great and I want you
to sit down with him and say here's who
I want us to be financially moving
forward to make sure you'll have that
conversation before you get way down the
road and like Dave I've been with the
same woman for more than half my life
now and this is a I don't know maybe
thirty five bucks at James Avery
something like that back in the day and
it works just fine so it works just fine
well you're not a lady so that's true
that's true you can get away with that
but yeah yeah so yeah this is a good
shape the good news here is it opens up
a great conversation because John and I
know that the statistics tell us that
number one cause of divorce is money
problems money fights money
disagreements and this gives you guys a
chance to align on that subject and him
to hear loud and clear how much you hate
that
and him to hear loud and clear that
you're willing to put your all's the
financial good of your future ahead of
the size of the rock on your hand you're
willing to make good mature decisions
together these are really good healthy
conversations for y'all to be aligned on
before he buys you a ring good for you
for asking
what a stud Shay that's awesome well
done kiddo very proud of you it's gonna
work out great and by the way go through
Financial Peace University as a couple
as our guests will go ahead and give you
an engagement gift Kelly I'll sign you
up hang on she'll pick up and get you
going on that so the all of the data and
you've seen you've heard me talk about
it but you've seen it from the
counseling world as well that if you can
get aligned on money it causes you to
get aligned on everything else you've
got a plan together talk together
communicate together and it's just what
a gift really good pre-marriage
counseling